we all want a sequel to red dead
redemption and we might have just gotten
our first look at the game's over world
I'm Tony and this is your Wild West
gamespot news update this image was
originally posted to neogaf by a user
named Midian but it was later taken down
TechRadar got a hold of the same image
and confirmed its legitimacy with an
anonymous source if it is indeed real
will be traveling to some familiar
places in redemption to the map shows
the Great Plains region which you might
remember as the location of Blackwater
from the first game you can also spot
new Bourdeaux which is actually the
setting for mafia 3 several islands are
shown too so the next red dead game
might feature some sailing mechanics red
dead redemption to has not been
officially announced by Rockstar but
reports say the game will actually be a
prequel we've reached out to the
developer for comment in the meantime
you can keep up with all the rock star
news at gamespot will tell you all about
Redemption to as soon as we hear more
you